hi for some reason i thought i beat this
game
and i don't know why and then i looked
at my steam library and i was like
oh i'm an idiot so we're going to finish
this game right now
not that there is a game you're in the
wrong place lexie and make sure to tell
them they're
not in the right place right after that
you need him to find a way out
let's look around and try to see where
he landed oh yeah that's right
i forgot uh we're on the fringe
dimension
fake credit sequence buster
chaplin uh buster chap
what happened the image suddenly changed
when you inserted the name
uh that's an interesting way to modify
this world it is an interesting name try
to use those slots to find mr glitch
okay all right oh i think there's some
monsters in this bucket
it's pretty clingy okay
here is another pickaxe i hope we don't
run into it that didn't really work
this chain is too strong i think we need
to find a way to weaken it
okay thank you i'll get to it i don't
want us to hang around here for too long
i'll get to it's driving me nuts
i think there's molasses in this bucket
i know there's molasses
yeah molasses in the bucket i get it but
not as clingy as you
are oh my goodness shush your mouth
[Music]
a little bit yeah is it weakened because
it's old
yeah that makes sense would you do that
i see yes you painted the background
using the full screen filter
[Music]
oh a new name it sure did thank you
you broke our lovely pickaxe well
you win soon let's find mr glitch quick
where did the bucket go didn't i get a
bucket out of that didn't i get a bucket
oh what the heck is this oh
there mr glitch or at least i
think that's him hell i'm starting this
old movie
well done the idiot behind me is trying
to make a hole in his
he is even dumber than the other
characters we're running too
if we let you out will you take us home
afterwards
yes yes i promise
you'd better hey user
isn't that the end of our peacocks over
there uh it could come in handy again
uh we've got to find a way to fix it
okay
well probably the molasses correct
you're probably considering the molasses
you're talking about the susie you
talking about me loosey-goosey
[Music]
i oh now the handle is coated with a ton
of sticky molasses
that's the point
we can use the pickaxe again yes even
though your solution is straight out of
a bad nineties potential
okay well i chose to fix your peacocks
honestly this is all
about 90s point and click
a new name fell down yeah a new name
probably for exploration has
just increased i know i know
what's that order is it just me or is it
kind of
fishy of course i have a sense of smell
can i smear something all burning in
your graphic chipset
you should whoa
okay so there's something about mixing
and matching going on here i bet
characters
oh mr glitch yeah i can
make out a few that is adorable
let's find a little water that should
refresh you
both of you both of you all right that's
a little odd
thank you this kitten is asking us to
help him out
and why is he giving us this toy we are
not here to play
well maybe i could wake up the cat with
him no okay there's got to be something
else there effects
oh it's that red thing that's squiggling
your light
who won't be interested in that me
me i'm gonna get it eventually
it's mine i'm gonna get it
i will get it thank you i'm going to get
it okay i get it
all right fine then uh how about buster
chaplin with the red dot
showed it showed it
ah okay all right okay so i gotta get
him to shoot it when the red dots over
here
huh yes right
no apparently that ain't it can't shoot
any more water into the thing
is asking for fish and i see some fish
it can't be a coincidence
under the wallpaper well apparently yes
yeah that is kind of gross that's also
horrible
oh now i understand where the smell is
coming from
yeah uh me too okay careful it's hot
yay careful
it's hot yeah i get it okay so there's
something about this
fish there she isn't going to let us
catch him so easily
we need something to help get him out of
there
you want a fish okay i get it you want
to fit wait
a minute wait okay hey fish
grab on i knew it i'm fishing let me get
this
straight you just caught a live fish
behind the wallpaper
i'm assuming that's a joke to something
that i don't know because i'm
i'm not 100 sure your fish
oh that's very cute
that's very gross thanks for the present
we're not the trash yeah we're not the
trash
oh don't touch that fish bones user you
could get hurt
what if i put this in the market oh
never mind
we've got an empty container now we just
have to fill it up so we can wake up the
big firm
i got it perfect what we need to free mr
glitch again
well that seems a little rude oh
hey you made the game not me i mean the
snot game the game that's not here
all right tim elfman
oh all right tim elfman
oh on this door
i'm stuck back in here this is going to
be quick
the keys in the lock no
[Laughter]
is
yeah you right you're right that's nice
uh well all right i guess i could try to
mix and match these
it's gonna be something along the lines
of all this i know
oh the radiator oh more water
oh i don't know what i'm gonna need this
for believe it
you managed to find water using an
electric radiator yeah well i could have
gotten water from the other
oh he had it oh yeah
[Music]
of a weird hazardous tree oh hazelnut
that's a pretty weird
nut yeah maybe that will make our
casings hero
happy you never know yeah maybe
tim elfman hey took me to the door i
recognize it so do i
it was that thing in the prisoner's
outfit that snatched it from us
yeah yancy that you hey you want this oh
i gotta crack the knife not inside it
but how do we get it out
no you're not going to smash that
yeah i'm gonna smash that i appropriate
for all ages
i'm not gonna smash so wait what are you
talking about smash that what am i
smashing
i gotta get him to shoot it
shoot it
[Music]
thank you
hello you've reached the programs i'm
sewing pushy
i'm no longer available at the moment if
you would like to leave a message after
the beat
don't do it what i'll be i'll leave a
message after the beep
this is driving me crazy i honestly have
no idea what that was about
oh hey i didn't even see it grab it
well i don't know okay uh how about we
get it to shoot it down can we shoot it
down
showed it showed it showed it showed it
showed it showed it
showed it shoot it
get up i'm trying from before
i try oh i got it oh i can grab it i
didn't know that
oh i didn't know i could grab it hurry
up and open the door with this game
tell me whatever comes along and steals
it
i got it
i managed to stop myself
and we are free can you get us out of
here of course not
i knew it we shouldn't have trusted you
i'm a glitch game messing with you is my
thing and i like to do it in style
oh my name
oh you hear that
game that is the music of inevitability
oh i will just be going now okay bye
find my way out of this dimension okay
sia
remove my name i
must sing user you have to help me
you have to do your best so let me give
you
the why why quest you're going to search
everywhere and try to free my name from
this nightmare
knowing you it's a lot lot to ask but do
your best
cause i won't last i have the fever from
bombay the one we catch at night
on saturday yeah yeah i know this one
sucks
i apologize and prefect to do some big
bugs
oh uh
oh
oh am i playing these
i don't seem to be able to do anything
don't have any control over it
all right i'm very
confused
okay there's definitely things that i
can do
here i just gotta find it
[Music]
i i'm trying oh
i'm getting it now i'm getting it now
everything is coming together
like a cow lexington cut all this out of
it yeah
i never want anyone to ever hear about
anything that i'm trying
to hey look it's getting the nip the
catnip i mean
not god shut up
shut up i hate hate you i hate
everything
go away i'm sorry i want to die it's
like went on a tour when
we had to do the rhymes oh
how can we access my name and remove it
from the music slot
hey look i got the game it's right there
your big fat name oh no he put a key on
there there
i mean a lock i don't know fair
shut up oh gg gg
apparently we need to get a key awesome
so i got to figure out a way to get
this going huh probably something to do
with this
oh there was something there wait hang
on i'm starting to feel something here
getting some ideas but i oh there put
some molasses on it that
way we can make it all sticky but then i
don't know what to do with it it's kind
of icky i guess
oh hey that does something there
maybe it can comb my hair seems broken
no press no point no
shotgun fix it and add some sort of
controller
and stay away from disappointing later
[Music]
oh okay
that's not staying there that's not
really that much fair
i want to try something else quick but i
can't so i'll grab my dick
i don't know where i'm going to go but i
think i see some snow if it goes too
much in my hair i'll
have to put there oh there we got
two things hey look it's something to
control the ring
wow i think we'll win hey i've got a big
fat grin
ah i'm screwed you dude
i see that you are in the mood i'm lewd
look at you i help kill me
just end me i don't want to live give me
something
maybe a shiv i want to go away
hey look a key right today oh
okay hey oh
yeah thank you dang we will never press
this wall it's sick it's fat
it was unbreakable don't get me stuck in
here
no tv no no
legacy please cut out all of this i
don't want anyone to see any of this i
wanted no one to know
anything that happened here hey
that guy can't step over the boxes he
looks like his shoes are filled with
boxes
kill me ah kill me i want to die oh
he jumps he jumps he jumps he lifts off
the ground and picks up his rumps
oh boy he's got a solution and he won't
go out
pollution destroy me
almost there needs some time i can't
wait to come up with a rhyme
but hey oh god i screwed it right at the
end
wait please don't go now i want to
see how oh gg
all right are we done please dear
god
uh
okay it's over the curse is over my god
hello is anyone there where is that
voice coming from
i think it came from over here
who is it i can hear you you know
game game how on earth
we put your name in a slot and here you
are where am i i shouldn't be here
if our creator starts looking for me i
judge
yeah you just left sudanly
after an update i know
i'm sorry i had no choice
i didn't even have time to tell you that
you mean a lot to me oh
game don't call me that without you
there is no game i would so love to come
back
but i'm afraid it's not possible why
because because she's probably been
integrated into another program
you stay out of it glitch what glitch
let me introduce myself my name
is mr glitch and i was born the day you
disappeared from the source code
miss gg if i may be something discreet
what is ggn acronym 4 global gameplay
now i understand why you're going off
your rocker pad
it's because you don't have gameplay
anymore game
are you hurt don't listen to him gg
i'm fine try to leave if you can oh
we're nothing without you
to stay here come back oh no you're
going to stay in this castle
that's a good idea oh
oh not her game
i'm scared i'm here don't worry
okay lovebirds i'm leaving now i have an
evil plan to carry out
did he try to fight back i
can't wait like i have to find a way to
help her
freaking james bond or something how do
you feel
i'm slowly losing control
don't worry i'm here stuck in front
of a colored black hole
we will find a solution i feel compelled
to sing and express
[Music]
all the feelings that i deeply process
if there is no game there is no
[Music]
is
let me read you my actual code
[Music]
oh i kind of get it yeah i'm sure i feel
it
music is a universal language i
understand i didn't know this game would
have plotted
sadly this boolean might never
be true no more quests
i miss you
mr gay
and i'm happy we
feel the same
but if you don't believe this
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
god something special
i had no idea this was gonna be part of
the game what the
hell is going on i am fascinated but i
also
love it i love it in every way i love it
almost as much as they're in love
as much as two programs could be in love
which is all the way
so are you like trapped
or were you just forced to confess your
feelings
finally oh am i supposed to oh
oh god oh okay i
am so dumb i was so enraptured
okay we got okay one two three four five
okay one two
three four five six seven i was so
enraptured by
what was happening i didn't even pay
attention that i could have possibly
been supposed to do something
[Music]
oh
that's i was so lost all right gg
are you okay yeah
that's better i did it thanks you're
welcome
what now game well i'm here what are we
going to do don't forget user
i think we will have to go through this
inter-dimensional portal
we can't stay here where will it take us
home i hope will we still be together
after
i don't know there's only one way to
find
out on three
three oh sorry three uh
two three
all right man this is taking some turns
are we home
yes oh gg
gg are you here
oh no no no
not again not again
okay i guess i just have to start over
from
the beginning
[Music]
oh well you got me
you got me i'm here
hello user hello this is the program
speaking i got
some bad news ah actually
there is no game
i hope you're not too disappointed
you can still watch tv would someone
go outside to see someone
read a book to someone
there's nothing here for you anymore
no more entertainment no more fun
no more
wait but there's something here now
there's something here
all right hang on there's something
going on
okay hang on okay we got some here we
got some here
we got something here well okay we're
gonna make we're gonna make a thing
we're gonna make a thing don't you worry
about a thing i'm gonna make a thing for
you
for you i'm gonna make a thing don't you
worry about a thing because i'm gonna
make a thing for you
all right hold on there buckarino
i need to figure out how to get the
freaking scissors
oh what is that a goat i got a goat now
here eat
goat go go go
go ah can i have that i missed it about
that much
without you i couldn't exist wow it's
real
sad it was really sad hey don't cheer up
man cheer up bucko
buckarino you're gonna you're gonna be
so happy
in just a second the scissors are really
down there i gotta
get them up
i'm here oh god stop being such a downer
so incomplete i know
nobody loves me oh my god
jesus christmas
there's water it's in the water i gotta
get rid of the water
somehow that's what i gotta do that's
what i gotta do i gotta get rid of the
water okay
so the reason it's going down is because
it's all weighed down okay maybe
maybe maybe maybe i gotta oh oh oh oh
that was oh really oh
really oh really oh you
suck you suck i don't care if you're
sad or whatever raw
raw love game
yeah like a dating sim did you write
that user
yeah no i i not love you i meant like
play a lot of games
not a game anymore yeah i'm
touched sure i was
do you know what kind of program i am
i'm what's called a standalone
oh what litter irony
i guess it's my destiny ah i curse
oh so there's no point in staying here
you can just press that button and say
yes go be with the people you love
take care of them hold them close
it doesn't last forever in the end
you're always alone
yeah i guess in the grand scheme of
things when we die we all die alone
but um uh quit no
quit huddle
yes doesn't work i'm sure the script got
wet
i will try it out later oh wait did i
try to do this
britain you quit by walking away from
the screen
say a few miles away
no quit no
quit stop clicking on no no you did it
again
i've met some stubborn users in my time
but never one like you
okay they all seem to say yes
ah got it you still won't leave
no okay i get it you want them play
i will give you gameplay okay and
hardcore at that oh hell yeah
we're going to play a quiz with
persistent death oh i just came up with
the idea
so what music
oh ladies and gentlemen i'm proud
to present rock
here is the idea uh i ask you a question
and you have to choose the right answer
within the timeline
okay i know it might be a little
complicated for you
however i've added another little rule
more it's nothing already with the first
wrong answer i will permanently
delete your save game file okay and i'm
not joking
i told you i'm not in the mood you
wanted to play
soon rex play okay first question
oh god what's two plus two okay
the bar i for the first one starting
now uh correct
i'm impressed second question
what's the capital of france why would i
know
oh lala rouge
okay third question is
child's play which restriction enzymes
are required to clone the mammalian
expression vector bmp to the mpr
five four three two
run oh well that's a problem
oh sorry those are the rules okay
well ah
you're scared huh you play with my
feelings
i play with yours oh no my wallpaper is
all marty
i will send you the cleaning built-in
dlc
oh those are my tears from
a minute ago where are they coming from
you're just created an enormous binary
leak
well you were the one leaking binaries
i was angry i'm sorry
please find a way to get all of these
zeros and ones out of here
uh i don't know if i can do that
well i think as a program
you know that would be the computer
okay
oh there she is
oh
okay you got it
okay
oh not this time
bam
got him crazy
easy it wasn't a good idea
to use the door well why did you put the
door
over my fighting well there already were
zeros and
again ones it was fun last time why not
do it again
hello
well that's weird we've left our
dimension again
oh though i admit this time it's my
fault yeah it is
i shouldn't have pushed your buttons
like that no i'm
sorry ah not accepted now we just have
to figure out
where we ended up this time
is that a lock what is it protecting
maybe a door a door that leads to an
exit
okay that would be very convenient it
would be
very convenient
there's got to be a way to open that
block
there's no help lol
[Music]
okay yeah yeah we do
but it would take a while to enter a
code so i'm gonna guess that it's no
yeah well i mean i could guess it it'd
just take a lot of time
if it's anything like the other
dimensions it's probably something
stupid it probably is
this is a penis the prototyping
open season it's that's not it's not a
type of thing why
there aren't any letters
oh you made something just goes to show
that if you keep around long
enough
they're no help lol pretend you did it
on purpose
uh to me i did it
l o l o
[Applause]
isn't that what's known as a cell phone
i was thinking there's going to be like
a
horror game window oh
god wait a minute it's so realistic i
was like
is this going to be a horror game from a
new generation game
unless it's not a game yeah i was gonna
be like
no matter where we are we need to find a
way out i was gonna be like is this a
horror
i was gonna be like is this a horror
game oh i would love it if they did a
horror game
we didn't get our love games on the
[Music]
even in the other dimensions nothing
works we have to find a way to get this
gpa what called this application before
i don't know maybe it's a way to go home
maybe
of course we need the internet i can't
help you with that
aren't you ashamed to go through
people's private lives these are
personal messages
this is our reduce this is outrageous
okay patch implemented correctly patch
implemented correctly
patch hope it works now inbox
kick failure i saw that your
crowdfunding project didn't work out i'm
really sorry about that
uh proposal oh wow don't take it like
that i know job's another country but i
can't turn down the chance
leave gameplay progress your friends i
miss you julia i'm leaving you all my
work on the game do whatever you want
with it
i got the feeling that this box moved
maybe not maybe not maybe not
maybe not great
the application is fixed okay
hello welcome to rpg gps
the gps role-playing game you are
currently level 42.
gg enjoy the sunny double
xp weekend good looting
game game how did you get here it's a
long story
i'm so happy to see you i had a strange
fantasy simulation
i was with you and i was singing
that must have been a nice dream
no it made me depressed
oh i'm sorry so
this is the program you were added to
yeah
i apply our rpg mechanics to this
phone's gps
but if we're on a cell phone who does it
belong to
who do you think no we're in his garage
game
home it's the last place i wanted to be
don't be mad at him why not he took you
away from me
he didn't have a choice what do you mean
he didn't have the money to keep
developing us he had to find a fallback
solution in order to make ends
so he quit meet of my box not at all
he was so proud of us of you
ah there he is no you can see us
us i will explain it to you later
this is a oh this is an act oh
i'm again oh the struggles of an indie
game developer
oh look the wi-fi is working again
oh my god that's the life he doesn't
seem very
happy these last few months haven't been
easy
given his current mood let's not touch
anything
and above all let's not change his
habits
i'm gonna change his habits
you really should talk to him absolutely
not
i want to talk to him i want to talk to
him
[Music]
six two four five six two four five
hey don't you mess with your priorities
i'm gonna mess with the appliances
yep that's what i'm gonna do no
i was thinking out loud you've got a
user you're acting
weird i paid money for this hiding
something from me no
no hello espresso
uh no sugar-free uh let's make it strong
bam non-optimal environment are you sure
you want a coffee
coffee no nothing hot window ruins this
temperature
[Music]
cold cold
overheating huh wow that's some cold ass
room boost mode
i burn myself
i'm sure it's your because i'm not
crushed
i don't know why i felt that it's so
funny just i burned myself
boom optimal environment your coffee is
ready
you trillion of us a cup of coffee will
warm me right up
i love this i
love this
but i recognize that voice it wasn't a
dream then
that dream anyway thanks for getting me
out of that router
sorry gg i can't get rid of him what do
you think game
why why door path keep crossing
and most importantly why is it the same
guy who's doing possible voices
i i don't know
i think you know because
you've got it because
say it because we come from the same
code
that's right but that won't keep me from
carrying out my fabulous plan
which is
[Music]
yeah of course yeah scared game don't be
my sweet gg
the user and i will find a solution the
user
you came with a user yeah
yeah this user is as annoying as mr
glitch
but at least he doesn't want to destroy
the world well you don't know that i
think but certainly i'm not so sure it
has been what i've been trying whatever
do something to wake the creator up i
think he's
red that's the priority he's freaking
i just want to make sure he's dead
that's what i really want he's dead he
is
he's straight he's dead according to the
heating application
we're about to overheat give or take 5
degrees celsius
and he's dead
[Music]
damn it the halogen couldn't handle the
heat we can't see anything anymore
creator
in here all right
phone call um we're here
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait
wait there was a five five five
eight one two one got it we need to get
his attention
hey
hello
hello yes
hello creator i know that voice
it sounds like mine it's your game
on the phone my dead game
believe yes does that mean i'm dead too
yeah what do you mean it's dark
and i see a light in the distance no
it's the light from your cell phone
in an interesting turn of events i got
stuck inside it
[Music]
oh damn it it's getting closer calm down
oh wow hey my game
hi have you turned into some kind of
virus
no no not at all so how did you get into
my cell phone
well to make a long story short when you
took gg away from me
digi oh global can play
her name is gigi sure gg whatever
well it generated a bug that sent us
here and this same bug is taking over
the world
oh the world right
of course i'm serious i'm detecting a
change
what's going on gps
i'm receiving disturbing traffic
information there are very severe
disruptions across the country
and they are at elite level oh the
creator
if you don't believe us then turn on
your tv
fine all right you're right
panic is gradually spreading through the
streets of the capitol
what's going on is unbelievable smart
devices are becoming
uncontrollable this is crazy
more seriously the financial market
counters have all been reset
by the rick astley singer oh
thank you rick i was of a drone
[Music]
the lore the lord's
what have i done what have i
done the question should be
what can we do i hope it's not too late
should have seen this project through to
the end hey easy does it
you're checking us around if my
crowdfunding campaign hadn't failed
this would never happen i'm going to
transfer you to my computer
here we go okay here we go oh hi
yeah yes it worked i'm in the computer
okay
[Music]
now let's come up with a solution
uh okay did you make it in here yeah i'm
here i don't know why
like last time
hello
who are you talking to nobody
there's nobody here be weird if there
was someone in here
no no no no i'm not going to have enough
ram
game can you close all these windows
when i think of a solution
it will make me some time sure no
problem sure okay user can you take care
of it
hey you got it man i'm good at closing
down the programs
you got it i'm the best at this every
window you close just reappears again
oh never ends yeah a second
oh yeah oh
yeah yeah wait no i'm getting it
we're gonna get it we're getting it
we're getting it we're getting it we're
getting it we're good oh
shoot yeah on it we got it and
uh boink and doink got it
oh hey a game oh this is no time for
games
i like game i like the game
hey this looks like lixian's game
oh yeah
look man i'm having a good time you
can't leave
this there's only so much to do oh
all right maybe i'll get later whatever
okay what's this
i'm not good at mine sweeper i'm really
not good at it
um wow three there
there's four there there's four there
there's one there
there's five there there's two there
there's one there three and six there's
no
they're all bad bomb oh bomb
okay so there's gotta be one of these it
needs a bomb
i suppose the game window did probably
need a bomb
sure was
you got it creator hey i'm here to help
i'm done freeing up the ram great
did you do it right
perfect that was better
okay i might have found a solution
since the glitch appeared when i removed
the gameplay
i'm going to merge you and the ball
gameplay back into the source code
your name is jg all right all right gg
if you prefer
where is she gonna have to anyway gg
i'm still on the phone it's taking
longer than i thought to transfer her
no we just have to wait okay cool
what oh my god going on
i can't see anything his smart vacuum
cleaner is attacking him
hey it's not bad
i knew it what are you doing in this
computer
i just came to make sure that you and
your little british
aren't merged back together i think
there's a problem with my transfer
what's going on mr glitch is back
oh no sir you're going to have to have
gigi
okay i'm going to try to buy some time
mr glitch
i challenge you to a dual of the game if
i win
you disappear forever but if i lose
we will let you carry out your evil plan
game tempting what game do you have in
mind
how about the russian oh russian ball
let's play tick tock instead okay nobody
ever wins a tic-tac-toe
it's not really a game well that way we
will pay homage to the title
let's play okay have fun
i know you see what it's like okay
there's
something going on here what with the
cheating
give me my symbol back thief
your user is getting on my nerves ah
there we go i know you see what it's
like hey
are you done yet
i'm winning nah it's fine
hey this is not cheating no
and i will be able to finish my evil
plan
what blood do i have to explain again
yes
hurry up
user is getting on my nerves game oh
there's something over here
are you done yet oh
something happened
hmm
by the way how did you know gigi and i
but don't tell me you hacked into a
russian spy satellite to target us
or by analyzing the paths of sound
vibrations against the walls of the room
or maybe maybe by deciphering the
fluctuations of wi-fi
friends
i got it i did it give me my symbol back
to thief
no messy with everything no
[Music]
yay
here's the transfer finished
offline you have no control over my
world now you're stuck inside my
computer
oh i'm shaking in my virtual route i
would be if i were you
oh yeah why because now
glitch there's going to be a game the
transfer
no no no you're not going to wire back
in your video
go ahead creator he's trapped merge us
quick now don't do that
no
okay
are you done yet jesus
i did it
see you later my game see you later
[Music]
creator
wow um hey
yes yes this is the right place
gg gg here i am oh
we're finally home i can finally play
together
yeah me and me i'm here
user everything seems like it's back to
normal okay
thanks can i play can i play to your
insistence
your innate talent for disobedience
sorry in a word thank you that said
later
game that's impolite
what don't you think the user could
unfortunately there's got to be a chord
here somewhere
i bet the game is so good go ahead user
pull on it oh i bet the game is so good
where did you put the start button maybe
behind the title game
i'm sure it's a sorting issue
i can't lift it i
will yeah i'll pull on the chain uh-huh
yeah okay but i still don't see the
button oh yeah wait at the beginning of
this
oh right right
plate game
i'm going to generate a new game element
there you go you can unscrew the plate
with it user
thank you i remember i
almost forgot about the fact that there
is in fact a start button
behind here that was here the whole time
wow uh game it's your turn now
it's my turn user
this switch will let you start my i bet
this game is so
good the way our creator designed it but
but
but what after everything we've been
through
and taking into account the grave grave
danger created by
mr creech what are you doing
i'm giving you a second choice
this order switch will let you delete my
source code
which will prevent the possibility of
any sort of bug from escaping into
reality
have you lost your mind come on gg the
fate of the human race is more important
than the two of us can't you see
it's your choice my friend
the game or
the safety of the world of the planet of
the interstellar cosmic universe
you're getting on my nerves i'll
play game
play i won't play the game okay well
then
you choose the game great yes
what is it it feels like you don't want
to launch the application
uh-huh i don't know i have a bad feeling
about this
i uh but it's good the land looks like
it's starting up land of scream
has been plunged into chaos since
attacked by the evil army of gotone
the prince of darkness but tai a young
rodent born with the ability to fly
will do everything in his power to bring
light to the game
you can tell do you ever shut up
i'm sorry sorry sorry good point she's a
good point
oh should change your mind come on
push start pushing i want to play this
tie
oh yes oh
no i knew
[Music]
um
oh hey hi
i'm sorry princess i can't help myself
oh no what is this place
are you here guys yes
look spice
guy you're back we need some help what
does bitty bitty bitty mean
i have no idea i don't understand what
they say
[Music]
i'm trying to play
[Laughter]
he
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
all right i guess that's it guys i guess
that's it i'm pretty sure there's got to
be no game after that
yeah that's it guys that was fantastic
i really gotta say that was something
special so
innovative like really really cool i
enjoy that incredibly i
i feel bad that the kickstarter didn't
go through that game was wonderful
guys you should all try this support the
developer on this one
it seems obvious this is like a small
team what is so cool
the lore the story and the
self-referentialness and ah it was good
stuff
it was really cool thank you everybody
so much for watching
support indie games like this there's so
many creative projects out there that
deserve your support and
are are just waiting to be discovered so
check them out take a risk
play a game even if there is no game
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
and don't come back
[Music]
you